the parts the nominee for the Best Actor
in a leading role played are all
basically challenged in some way I think
they're time challenged so why don't we
just cut to the chase here and let's
just give this lucky guy in extra 11
seconds that's where I go ahead okay the
nominees for Best Actor in a leading
role are Tom Cruise in Jerry Maguire
raise funds in the English Patient
Woody Harrelson and the People vs Larry
Flynt
geoffrey rush and shine
Billy Bob Thornton in Slingblade
and the Oscar goes to Geoffrey Rush and
shine
I want to thank the members of the
Academy I'd also like to thank every
Australian actor and theatre colleague
I've ever worked with there's a game you
can play where you create a dinner party
where you can invite guests from any
time in history real or fictional the
Academy has honored me by choosing to
seat me as David Helfgott at a table
with Larry Flynt and countless Ladell
mushy and Kyle Childers and Jerry
Maguire I can't quite imagine where the
conversation might head that night but
it has been it has really enriched me as
an actor to be seated at that table
I want to thank Scott Higgs and all the
shine team for giving me the chance to
have a glimpse of the bird of paradise
Scott thank you my darling wife Jane I
wouldn't be standing here without you
and to Merle and John my mum and stepdad
in Queensland and to the unstoppable
David Helfgott
the front of my script said that this
story was inspired by the events of your
life you truly are an inspiration and to
those people who say it's a circus then
with your celebration of life you show
me that the circus is a place of daring
and risk-taking and working without a
safety net and giving us your personal
poetry thank you